my name is Bill Irwin I'm Patti Irwin
and we've been married for 35 years five
years ago today I retired as a special
agent with the FBI
and have been in consulting since then
we've been able to work together at home
here and get to do things that we want
to do not what other people want us to
do as an FBI agent
we had a retirement that required us to
retire by the age of 57 which was
something that I think concerned patty
greatly that's true I have more security
issues especially financially because
I'm the nerd and numbers didn't add up
that he could retire and then we just
live on his pension we at that time were
pretty ignorant as to what the future
was going to look like we didn't have a
plan we didn't know that people really
had plans has no turret Church some
things happened that caused us to look
at things differently
we had some families that were having a
lot of financial issues and some really
intractable problems that that were very
concerning for us about that time one of
our members came to us and said that he
wants become a financial coach he wanted
the church to send he and his wife to to
Nashville to go see and talk to some guy
named Dave Ramsey we saw the need so
when crisp and Alisa freeman approached
us and asked to go to Nashville we were
in agreement that this was a great idea
the couple went this kind of weekend
came back and started doing financial
coaching and then we set up a Financial
Peace University class I think we went
to the class to support the class we
discovered some things that were kind of
disconcerting we weren't doing as well
as we thought we were
and that there was a plan there was a
way to do this much better
[Applause]
before we went to FPU I had the
assumption that he was on board the
whole time and when I found out that he
wasn't and he really didn't have a clue
where her money was going that was a big
turning point we were pretty much on a
budget anyways but I was the only one to
do it
because it was in my head he didn't know
what the budget was I just told him you
can't do that
he didn't understand how he was making
really good money but he never had any
money a real turning point for me is
when we started doing a written budget
and sitting down and talking about our
finances we have we have such starkly
different styles when it when it comes
to things like money that if we don't
talk about it we're going in different
directions because I'm the dreamer I'm
the one that that that looks more over
the horizon patty concentrates on the
here and now and one of most important
things to talk about or what are your
dreams what are your goals for the
future what do you really want to
accomplish we hadn't been having those
conversations because we're you know
everybody's working everybody's rushing
and no one's paying attention to where
you want to end up we're much closer as
husband and wife because now we've
shared dreams we have shared goals what
that what a budget is is if it's a
template it's a plan for the future and
I was good with that when we sat down to
do the budget it made perfectly good
sense to me
I just never occurred to me before a
couple of months ago the day that you
contacted us to talk about doing this
interview was the day that we actually
made the last payment on this house we
paid off the mortgage it was all done
online just transferring money and so we
don't have a mortgage
[Music]
we've got a paid-for house we've got
income we've got investments this puts
us in a position to to actually do the
things that we want to do to volunteer
to try to make a difference in people's
lives rather than than making money our
church has a number of large projects
that are what actually brings people
together for is they have a common goal
to do these things at months a CERN's
home was founded around 1960 a visionary
group of Christians in the Denver area
saw a need for this and set it up and
got it running and it's just outside of
Longmont in Boulder County their goal is
to take in kids that for some reason
can't be in their own home and they get
weekly individual and group counseling
and the whole goal of the children's
home is to get these kids reunited with
their families on a regular basis there
in our house and we're showing them that
a family is is a good thing something
that many of these kids aren't going to
learn from their families
I think there may be a myth about
retirement and that is that you don't
really retire until you die because you
still have to do something we probably
would not ever be completely retired
like some people would think laying on
the beach all day because there's really
nothing to that a wife lived with people
and the quality of the relationships you
have that's really important simply
taking care of ourselves is okay but
it's not fulfilling in a long term it's
in service to causes larger than
yourself that you feel life has meaning
it's where the rubber meets the road one
things we discovered on on our journey
was attending Financial Peace University
the first time was a life-changing event
we've done it twice more sense as
helping to coordinate the classes
because it was life-changing event for
us it caused us to look at the world
differently and much more realistic with
[Music]
you develop a plan and then you work
your plan which is basically all that
the Financial Peace University is you're
given a template for what success can
look like you overlay your life on to
that template and you're probably going
to find success it's that something
[Music]
you
[Music]